doesn't seem like everything's changing
so quickly one minute FTX is the company
to be part of 32 billion dollars guy
raised two billion dollars Sequoia
BlackRock next thing you know they go
down binance is not given the money the
guy says I left up and then they just
resign and the company is not filing
bankruptcy tutors going to Twitter blue
no we're not going Twitter blue yes we
are going Twitter blue Market's going up
markets going down this person's getting
elected that it's such constant change
chaos it's probably the most
unpredictable time in a long time where
most things cannot be predicted today
right economy elections all that stuff
so in Seasons like this how should you
and I react okay if you get value from
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel there's a whole
concept of thermostat versus thermometer
okay a thermometer the temperature could
change this morning I'm working on the
in my gym at the house all of a sudden
I'm sweating so by the whole floor is
wet because I'm sweating and I realize
the AC wasn't on in that room but it was
on in the other room so we look at the
temperature around 82 degrees or 82
degrees 6 o'clock in the morning what
the hell is going on here my wife comes
in she's trying oh my God it's so hot
yeah the temp the thermostat constantly
changes right
we go in the other room this one had a
thermometer because it's changing the
other one had a thermostat set at 72.
Club room cool right you go in there you
feel debris it felt great one room's
changing based on whatever the
conditions are the other room's like no
if the conditions get too warm we bring
it to 72. if the conditions get to this
we bring it to 72 it doesn't matter what
it is you're gonna come at my Pace
because I control the pace right
as crazy as things are right now as
insane as things are right now the
market with mortgage rates or interests
with inflation with economy with
election with everything
this is the perfect season to be a
thermostat choose your temperature and
stay there this is the wrong time to be
a thermometer because if you're acting
like a thermometer
the market decides how your attitude is
going to be the Market's going to decide
how your mood is going to be the economy
is going to decide how you come to work
how you treat people how you do customer
service how you deal with your family
how you deal with your husband how you
deal with your wife with your kids with
everybody around you because you're up
and down up and down up and down up and
down up and down I haven't met many
great leaders that are constantly up and
down who do big things in their life so
choose a thermostat
choose a temperature you want to be at
and stay there and don't let anybody
around you change your temperature you
want to be at very hard to do I don't
say it's easy very very hard to do
but if you do that it's going to serve
you very well anyways if you got value
from this message give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel and if you
want to go deeper on this topic there's
a video I Shot two years ago called the
rules of mental toughness if you've
never seen it click here to watch it
take care everybody bye
[Music]